- Nicole, I hope to gosh
you have Speedy with you.
- Don't you worry, Speedy is right here.
(Drew laughing)
- Oh, thank goodness.
'Cause I was like, Jeremy,
we might look crazy if
Nicole doesn't have Speedy.
Wait, how old is he?
Because Jeremy is, here I'll take her,
and by the way, Jeremy is a girl.
I love the name Speedy, by the way.
- Thank you so much.
I actually heard, by the way, that Speedy,
I just got news from Speedy's doctor
that Speedy might be a girl.
- Well, you know what?
I have some information to offer you.
- Please do.
- I am Dr. Drewlittle so.
- Oh my god, Dr. Drewlittle!
- So Dr. Drewlittle found out
that if you'd like to figure out
the sex of your bearded
dragon, here's how.
- Okay.
- So under this part of
the tail, right there,
but underneath, you will
feel a nub if it's a girl,
and a prong if it's a boy.
Does it feel like it has
like a wishbone or a turtle?
- It's a nub, it's a nub.
Speedy, you're a boy.
- No!
The nub is a girl.
- Oh, what?
- Yes, Speedy's a girl!
- Speedy.
Oh my god.
You know what?
I love my children, no
matter who they are,
no matter what sex they are.
So I'm fine with it.
Has Jeremy the girl puffed
out her beard at you?
- She has with Lucky, our cat.
In the Dr. Drewlittle home it's nuts.
- Same.
- And Jeremy and Lucky the
cat, they fully are besties.
And Lucky will lick
and kiss Jeremy's face.
And every once in a
while, Jeremy will puff,
and just be like, I've had enough.
- Feel for the nub or the prong
is gonna be my new life motto.
We're gonna do a double feel after.
I'm gonna check one more
time after we're done.
Because, now that I know, I'm like, okay.
- And by the way,
if you shine a light on this side
it will come through, and it will
illuminate the nub or the prong.
Kind of like an x-ray.
- Okay.
Speedy, we'll do this tomorrow
because I feel like this has
been a lot for you today.
- Okay, I wanna talk to
you about Nikki Fresh.
This is, people are freaking out.
You constantly know
how to hit with things.
You just are such a tastemaker.
You have such impeccable style.
You're so darn cool.
And this, I feel like, is just
the perfect vehicle for you
to put everything into
in this melting pot,
and here out comes Nikki Fresh.
How did you come up
with the whole persona?
- Well, so it all started
with, so I've been,
I've had an edible garden.
I started that about
six or seven years ago.
And the idea of gardening
and growing your own food
was just something that
was very interesting to me.
And then, once I started doing it,
I just really fell in love with it.
And my friends sometimes
would make fun of me like,
oh, you're an old lady, this
isn't cool, whatever, whatever.
And I would be like,
how does gardening have this reputation?
I actually feel like it's
the most cool and exciting.
And like, how do I
communicate to the masses
how amazing, exciting,
spiritual gardening is?
And I was like, well,
I think I have to do
it through trap music.
But then I was like,
I can't do trap music,
I have too much respect for the genre.
So I'm gonna create my own
genre, which is parent trap.
Which is, people like
us, moms that love music
and love to have a good time.
That's you and me Drew.
Who love to have a good time and dance,
but like, I'm not up at 11:00 PM.
And you know, so my
peak hour is in the car
right after I drop off the kids at school.
So like, I need music for that too.
- Sometimes I feel like
this is tapping into
a part of me that was alive
and well many years ago,
and maybe hasn't totally died,
but wants to rebirth in a healthy way.
- Yeah, the only thing
that's died are my hours.
- Discos.
- Are my midnight hours.
But, I'm still very much the same person.
And I love dancing, you know?
- I love that you're saying this.
It makes me feel a lot less crazy
for having my inner
Disco Dolly still intact.
- No, my inner Disco
Dolly is still right here
and on this show with you.
- Oh, I love it.
With our beardies.
- With our beardies.
- All up in the club.
- Our male/female beardies.
- With our beardies.
- I mean, I used to, this
is so bad and embarrassing,
but I had a snake named
Cleopatra, a ball python,
and I used to take her to clubs.
I mean.
- That is so dope, I'm sorry.
- It's very '90s, early 2000s.
Like, uh.
(upbeat music)